sydney sweeney is rocking some major
bling that's sparking engagement rumors
because it just so happens to be a
diamond on that finger i wasn't even
expecting that here's the euphoria star
stepping out in los angeles on monday
sporting a pretty casual look wearing a
pastel colored zip up hoodie sydney's
also rocking a new hairdo looks like
she's switching up her signature blonde
locks for darker redder tresses but her
new look isn't distracting us from the
glacier on her left ring finger which
has everybody speculating that she's
engaged am i even allowed to say i don't
know
e.t has reached out to sydney's rep for
comment on the ring now who could
possibly be the lucky guy well the white
lotus star has never confirmed her
relationship but she's been linked to
restaurateur jonathan devino since 2018.
and it's no surprise jonathan doesn't
work as an entertainer because just last
month sydney opened up in cosmopolitan's
love issue about why she prefers to date
outside of hollywood quote i don't date
people in the spotlight i don't date
actors or musicians or anyone in
entertainment because i can just be
normal sid that way and it's easiest one
thing we know the actress is celebrating
the end of another wild season of
euphoria lex you really outdid yourself
i mean where did she find these
knockoffs it's quite an experience and a
roller coaster for them
there is some wreckage
there's definitely wreckage and through
the show's wreckage it seems the 24 year
old has found some special friendships
check out these behind the scenes pics
sid shared with her castmates filming
the show's second season
season two was big for sydney's
character cassie and her relationship
with her on-screen sister lexi played by
maud apatow you're the star of the night
she's always wanted to be the star
this is your big moment
shine please don't stop please stop
stop i should stop
me
i'm not the one putting on a play to
humiliate and embarrass you sure things
got pretty complicated between the girls
but off screen it's a different story
mod oh my gosh you know sydney had said
she wanted to share more scenes with you
this season what was it like for the
both of you to explore that sister
dynamic it was so fun i think like
we're like best friends so we had so
much fun
shooting together and
yeah i think i mean there's so many
things that are explored this season
that weren't the first season and i
think their dynamic is a lot more
complicated than you would expect so
yeah sydney would you agree with that
would you describe it as complicated no
completely i was actually saddened to
see how complicated it became as this
went on because i was like no sam i want
to keep working with mod more and more
though
seeing what the sisters did to each
other started to
sort of break me and the good news is
we'll be seeing more of that sister
dynamic play out hbo renewed the series
for season three but sydney isn't so
sure about where cassie's journey will
take her next at the end of the season
she definitely
self sabotages everything in her life
and she hits a whole new low that you
didn't even think she was possible going
to
season three you know
i
no because season one i thought cassie
had her [ __ ] together
i thought she was gonna be confident she
was gonna find herself and there was
gonna be a really cool like woman
awakening inside
and then i was just like slapped in the
face cassie's not
there so i have no idea what she's going
to do next season
[Music]
you